Tron legacy Disney's neon infuse sequel to the 1982 classic includes a
particularly egregious example of a trope that has bothered me for years.
It's a gendered convention that will be instantly familiar to science fiction
fans.
The convention shows up over and over again in speculative media,
but it didn't have a name,
so I gave it one.
I call it born sexy yesterday.
She said,
I saw the character of Cora is an isomorphic algorithm or ISO.
Basically,
she's a sentient computer program in the shape of a woman.
She's the miracle now.
Everything I ever worked for
a digital frontier to reshape the human condition
as the last of the ISOS.
Cora is described it this way.
Profounding naive
on imagine a play wise.
If that sounds vaguely like something someone might say about a child,
it's no accident because that's exactly how tron legacy portrays Cora,
but between you and me,
Jules furnace,
my favorite,
do you know Jules Verne?
Sure.
What's he like?
She has the mind of a naive yet highly skilled child,
but in the body of a mature,
sexualized woman.
She also serves as our heroes love interest.
Profoundly naive yet unimaginably wise captures the essence of this trope.
Born yesterday is an idiom meaning extremely naive,
inexperienced,
or ignorant.
Hey,
thanks.
I'm too stupid,
Huh?
Uh,
no,
he's right.
I'm stupid and I like it.
Okay.
You do
activated
as immediate trope,
foreign sexy yesterday as both a figurative and in many cases a literal meaning
in 1997 the [inaudible] cult classic.
The fifth element is probably the most quintessential example of born sexy
yesterday
told you perfect.
Like Cora Lilu is whimsical and naive.
Yeah,
but she's also deliberately framed in a sexualized way.
Make perfect.
I know the female characters that this trope is built around are defined by
their innocence of an experience with worldly things,
especially when it comes to sex,
romance,
or basic social interaction.
What do you mind if I kissed you
through the use of science fiction conventions they're brought into the human
world already fully formed the mind of a child manifest in a mature female body.
She may be an Android,
a computer program,
a mermaid,
an alien,
a magical being or otherwise raised in an environment isolated from the rest of
human society.
Many of these female characters have one very specific thing in common.
They're all deliberately written to be completely unaware of their own sex
appeal.
This then provides film makers with an excuse to include at least one scene in
which she disrobed in front of men.
And because she's so naive,
she doesn't understand the implications of this action.
As you might imagine,
there's quite a bit of overlap here with the manic pixie dream girl trope.
Where does the water come from?
Uh,
well the uh,
the water comes from the pipes.
The pipes get it.
Although characters who are born sexy yesterday are often highly skilled at
something that men will respect.
Frequently that thing has common.
Now,
so far we've only focused on the female characters associated with this trope,
but it isn't really about that.
Like most things in Hollywood born sexy yesterday,
he has written for men and ultimately it's a relationship.
True.
Perfect.
So that means we need to talk about the other side of the equation.
The male heroes,
typically he's a straight red blooded man who has for a variety of reasons,
found himself alone or unsatisfied in love.
He finds himself disenfranchised or otherwise direction.
He either can't find or doesn't want a woman and from his own world,
a woman who might be his equal in matters of love and sexuality.
He does have one thing going for him that he knows all about living life as a
normal human being.
It's too bad you don't eat food like find.
It can be quite pleasurable once you get pleasure out of food here.
If you want my secrets,
you'll eat my sandwich.
Of course.
So does every other guy on earth,
which should make him unremarkable.
Ju Ju except to a woman born yesterday because she's presumably never known
another man.
He would seem like the smartest,
most amazing guy in the entire universe.
How much cheese on Rye with mail,
and here's where we start to see how the trope is constructed as a male fantasy.
It's precisely her naivety and her innocence that allows her to see something
special in him.
Something that other less innocent or more experienced women cannot estimated
times 600 seconds.
Now we don't have time to go into it here,
but born sexy yesterday is absolutely everywhere in Japanese anime.
Now I should note that born sexy yesterday is not a modern trope.
In fact,
it's been a fixture of classic Hollywood science fiction films since the
beginning of the genre as well as intriguing.
I wanted to just how far women would permit this to go.
There's nothing really personal,
just a kiss
to kiss each other.
It's an old custom,
all of the really high civilizations going forward,
but it's good for you though.
It stimulates the whole system.
As a matter of fact,
you can be in tip top health without it.
I'd be only too happy to show you.
Thank you very much.
Forbidden Planet in 1956 is one example.
The time machine in 1960 is another.
Wow.
What's your name?
How do you spell it?
Spam.
Spelled right.
Country ride.
Then there's the character of Nova from the original planet of the apes.
Okay.
Touch you to smile.
Who is the protagonist?
Love interest.
Despite not understanding the concept of language.
The troop usually involves a white women,
but born sexy.
Yesterday is an offshoot of a much older media convention
monkey,
one in which white adventurers discover indigenous women.
Although in this case,
science fiction replaces colonialism,
has the mechanism driving that narrative.
I had a boom,
boom,
Bada boom,
Bada boom.
Big,
big motto.
Phone
still sometimes it's a little of both.
One sexy yesterday fetishize is the stark power imbalance between a wiser,
more experienced man and I'm naive,
inexperienced woman.
It's the ultimate teacher student dynamic.
It's the customer by people to help.
I don't know,
one more intro.
Star Trek is famous for making frequent use of this truck.
Perhaps infamous is a better word because the trope shows up in the original
series and then in every other series afterwards.
This
is this also
you could call it.
That
helped me.
Once again,
let's start by doing something different with your hair.
Seven of nines relationship with the doctor on Star Trek.
Voyager is a prominent example,
especially as depicted in the episode.
Someone to watch over shaking your head a little bit.
Is this more appropriate fans of that series will remember that the doctor's own
social naivety is never framed by the show as something sexy.
Actually I choose.
I think you'd look very nice and this one,
I am uncertain how to wear such a garment.
Assist me.
Oh,
I'm sure you'll manage.
I'll go prepare the holiday.
Remember the idea is to have fun tonight.
I'll expect a full report in the morning.
Hold on.
Born sexy.
Yesterday was a major part of seventh character at least to begin with.
She is ultimately made much more than that and outside of a handful of rather
cringeworthy episodes.
Seven story is largely one of self realization and self discovery,
which manages to transcend the constraints of the trope
to a large degree.
This is also true of a character like Somnio four five one from cloud atlas like
seven romantic relationship is downplayed while her character development is
made.
Central.
No.
Unless you send mirror and for first time in my life I was allowed to see how
high was and who I might be calm,
which brings me to this point.
The problem with this trope is not necessarily with the female characters
themselves.
If these were simply stories involving naive extra terrestrial women who learned
about love and humanity,
then that wouldn't be an issue.
Likewise,
if the male hero was also inexperienced in our two protagonists,
could discover love and sex together,
then that would avoid most of the troubling power dynamic issues.
What's going on.
You need to understand how it works,
what
this chip
his body,
so for example,
Cameron from the Sarah Connor Chronicles TV show,
it's the true but her relationship with a young John Connor is framed as much
more of a mutual exploration
since born sexy yesterday hinges on a lopsided power dynamic.
It's almost never portrayed the other way around.
It's extremely rare for a more experienced female character to teach a naive man
about sex.
I think you better go home now Mary sue,
why I think I might be ill or
something's happening
that's supposed to happen.
It is.
Trust me.
Well,
wait,
no,
no.
It should just
perhaps that's because most grown women don't find the idea of dating and
inexperienced adolescent boy.
All that.
Okay.
Peeling.
I don't know.
But uh,
you need that last so much first.
So fast.
On the rare occasion when the gender is our first male ineptitude,
then becomes the butt of the joke.
Right?
This is the woman from the baseball card store.
Remember me?
Oh yes.
Hi.
Hello.
Diggity dog.
Thanks for calling me on the telephone.
She may even end up falling for him,
but she falls for him despite his inexperience,
not because of it.
Oh,
sorry.
I forgot about the auto wash.
Worn sexy yesterday is about an unbalanced relationship,
but it's also very much connected to masculinity.
The subtext of the trope is rooted in a deep seated male insecurity around sex
and sexuality.
The crux of the trope is a fixation on male superiority fixation with holding
power over an innocent girl.
But in order to make that socially acceptable,
science fiction is employed to put the mind at that girl into a sexualized adult
woman's body.
It's a fantasy based on fear,
fear of women who are men's equal in sexual experience and romantic history and
fear of losing the intellectual upper hand to women
in Woody Allen's 1973 comedy sleeper,
the protagonist is frozen and when he wakes up in the future,
he's suddenly and very conveniently the only man left on earth who still
remembers how to have sex.
That same exact thing happens just alones character in demolition,
ma'am
are all fluid transfer activities like this better,
better,
so born sexy.
Yesterday is a science fiction trope that's designed specifically.
So male heroes get to automatically be the most extraordinary man in a woman's
life again,
because they're basically the only man to have ever been in her life.
As such,
the true rests on some troubling patriarchal ideas about female purity and
virginity.
By definition,
characters born sexy yesterday,
have no past lovers and no previous sexual experiences.
She is framed as pure and innocent sexually and romantically unchanged and
uncorrupted by the attention of other men.
The male hero therefore avoids even the possibility of being compared,
of being judged,
of not measuring up.
I never knew.
At the end of the day,
this is a male fantasy about escaping the humiliation of rejection.
Since he's the first end,
only man in this woman's life,
he gets to be the best by default.
Okay?
Which means he doesn't even have to try it.
Better partner,
a better boyfriend or a better lover.
That's what we call it.
Kiss.
Of course,
the reality is that life experience is a plus,
not a minus in relationships.
Okay?
And we need more media to reflect that.
We need media and where men enthusiastically embrace women who are their equals
equals in everything,
including in matters of love and sex.
So do all you would be science fiction writers out there.
I'll leave you with this.
Innocence is not sexy.
Knowledge and experience on the other hand,
now that that's extremely sexy,
if you'd like to see more videos related to media and manhood,
just hop on over to my patrion page and help fund the pop culture.
Detective agents.
Yeah.